[Music]
next up though is a live interview with
researchers working on conversational
agents one of the areas in which
Microsoft Research is a pioneer I'm
having a conversation today with Lucy
Vander Wende
I hopefully said that write a bill Dolan
of Microsoft and of course Allan Ritter
of the Ohio State I added the V in there
for you Thank You professor for me Ohio
State University they want to talk to us
today about well talking they did a lot
of researching conversational systems
welcome Lucy bill and Alan how you doing
thank you fantastic so what are some of
the interesting things happening in
conversational agents anybody can take
that well in the past in NLP what we
used to do is build models that really
involve a lot of hand coding to try to
decide how to respond to a given input
and in the last several years the field
has been overtaken by newer data-driven
techniques that allow us to train models
on huge volumes of naturally occurring
data specifically from social media
where we can find for the first time we
can really get access to enormous
volumes of text involving people having
a passion for conversation I remember
the first conversational agent I ever
wrote was the typical Eliza you know
this isn't that anymore all right what's
the what's the difference between Eliza
and the stuff that were working on here
once you take that oh yes I think Eliza
is doing something pretty interesting
but it's like how it's actually built is
really simple it's just a very small set
of regular expressions or handwritten
rules whereas here we're really trying
to learn how to build conversational
agents just from lots of data
learning them using techniques from
statistical machine translation okay so
the physical machine translation was
something that I got to work on a little
bit I'm not understanding the link
between machine translation and a
conversational AIDS and want to pay them
think of it as there's the language of
the person who's doing the speaking and
the language of the person who's doing
the curing so for example you say I'm
going to I'm going to Las Vegas tonight
I'm going to say have a nice flight
right it's a kind of a translation you
say one thing and I'm quite conditioned
to say you know one of a couple of
things or you know what are you going to
do there so it's kind of an input and an
output the difference between
conversation and machine translation is
that in machine translation the content
is all given to you and you just have to
faithfully do the translation with
conversation generation you're also kind
of deciding what to talk about that's a
bit of a difference tre there's some
content selection going there so how
like when I'm thinking of machine
learning I'm thinking of there's a
target output or I'm looking for a
specific task that I'm solving when I
talk about conversation in generalities
I'm having a hard time nailing down the
task and when I can't do that the
computer has a hard time so bill what
what is it what's the time no that's
your background in machine translation
shows because that is exactly one of the
challenges that we face with this work
that as when she was saying in
translation the semantics of the input
defines the semantics of the output
you're you're trying to affect the form
but the semantics needs to remain
constant across that transition in this
conversational space you're right it's a
wide-open field potentially you can
respond in any way to what I might say
to you but we are taking advantage of
the fact that there as this is saying I
see
each amount there's a huge amount of
predictability in our responses not so
much in what we say but how we say it so
for example if you ask me a yes-or-no
question there's a lot that's going to
be predictable about the form of that
response sure if what you're saying is
there's a lot of sort of polite
conversation chitchat back and forth
that is highly predictable if I say you
know as what you're saying is if I send
one to the airport you liked it they
have a nice slide or where are you going
or are you going on vacation something
like that and what we have done in in
translation there's a metric that has
been very powerful in helping decide
whether a changing made to the algorithm
was good or not blue which is an
automated metrics trained editor and
we've adapted blue in this
conversational state to allow ourselves
to in an automated way decide probably
whether that change we just made for the
algorithm was good enough and you said
it's called blue and blue in translation
that's the algorithm so everybody
valuation metric so I maybe I'm a little
older I don't remember blue but can you
talk a little bit about what that metric
is and how it actually applies to again
I'm having a hard time actually I know
you've entered it having a hard time
matching the two wanted to figure out
sure sure yeah blue is like an automatic
evaluation metric so one way you could
evaluate translations is to have people
look at a translation like an expert
translator and say is this a good
translation right whereas blue will
actually compare the translation against
the reference translation and try to
determine whether it's correct right
because there's a lot of different ways
you could translate a sentence like
reference that means the too many
generators yeah yeah and by the time you
take a sentence in English and
translated ten times that the Japanese
10 different people translate into
Japanese you've begun to cover the space
of multiple translations a Japanese and
now you can look
Ngram overlaps so word sequence overlaps
between the way your system translates
that input sentence and the way humans
and we've done something very similar in
this conversational space looking again
on social media for inputs that have
across this huge body of text of data
many different responses produced by
many different people so we can do
something very similar given this input
we predict the response is this now
compare sequences of words than that
that predicted response to what we found
across the corpus wrote what people
actually said when I'm going to the
airport was other than the input and so
again the space of possible responses is
infinite but you can begin to cover it
in this way if you have enough data I
think in conversation the space of
Rapinoe outputs is much larger than
translation rate so in translation the
input and output are semantically
equivalent to each other for kind of a
more constrained problem it's not
totally infinite right because
conversation like successful
conversation runs along their
cooperation cooperative principles and
I'm not going to be redundant so if you
ask me a question like Eliza
pretty much worked because Elijah asked
the question you are compelled to answer
right so you are getting tricked into
falling into the rut but you fall into
process that's what we have swapper
ative people in a conversation
and so to be cooperative also when you
asked me if if you say something I'm not
going to say oh yeah my hairpin is blue
because the total non sequitur
so the space of things that are relevant
to say in a conversation is not infinite
it's not deterministic I could say a
couple of things I have some flexibility
but I'm not going to totally go off the
rails either photos and that's what we
do as people you know you you have when
you say something you kind of predict
what I might say what I might start
talking about but the thing that makes
it interesting is when we slightly veer
off topic when I introduce a new theme
and that makes conversation engaging so
I like again like my challenge that I'm
having right is when I'm doing
translation there is a specific output
and you mentioned nine reference
translations right but when we're
looking at conversational topics like
I've had my four-year-old come out of
left field and say yeah I mean let me
just interrupt because I completely
agree with everything you're saying and
I also did not think this approach was
going to work but Michelle Kelly who's
him in the group or researcher who is
machine translation person he was
completely convinced that the same kind
of automated method would work in this
state and to my surprise it does because
so much of the response is predictable
even if the specific content is not if
you say are you going the response is
very likely to be yes I am
not something around and just that yes I
am no one not is enough to give us some
signal as to whether we're probably
doing something reasonable with this
algorithm or not and it's really
critical to have an automated metric
like this because it's the combination I
would say they want to correct me at the
service
I think translation really began to leap
forward all validation when you've got
the confluence of a lot of data on
parallel data that automated metric and
better machines you know I think yeah
that troika allows the steel to leap
forward because without that automated
method glue you know in the old days you
had to wait for people to manually store
your translations it would take a lot of
money and a lot of time to decide
whether that tweak you made yesterday
was a good day
and once you could hit a button and get
an instant read on whether you made
probably an improvement or not things
really began to accelerate and in this
conversational space began that
evaluation finding an automated
evaluation that is a critical component
it's is really making progress in the
fishing loading area so when I started
machine translation we did this thing
called a noisy town walk is it is it the
same thing if I don't know what state of
the art is in machine translation
anymore yeah so when we first started
doing this when I was first doing an
internship at MSR and so you were you
were actually at Microsoft as an intern
yeah that's awesome
yeah those are that this was like 2010
and this was really the first attempt in
the field to build data-driven that's
exactly when I finished my rad school
was it no actually I had to why we did
until 2012 so that was right around the
time that I was yeah this was really
what Allen did was really the first
attempt to take parallel data in the
form of input response and learn a
translation model summit that's going to
predict there
yeah yes I mean I think I was just
really in the right place at the right
time I think Microsoft Research was one
of the first places really investing a
lot of effort and data-driven
conversation thing and yeah we were you
know when we first arted out we were
using these really do channel type
models but recently the neural network
translation models has become more
popular for both machine translation and
in conversation and is that because the
deep learning models are better at
taking a lot of input or I mean I'm
trying to understand because like I said
right at 2010 you remember that's when
everyone was like oh deep neural
networks don't work and then all of a
sudden they really did because of the
depth and it it's actually interesting I
think the models that Ellen built tended
to produce more interesting responses
but they weren't very fluent and with
the advent of neural models that same
data dumps into the neural model so this
is move area yeah that's a very fluent
response words that tend to be blamed
the model tends to produce this very
that a very though statistically safe
response never gets a no big challenge
has been to try to goad it into saying
something more like a Boltzmann some
motion at state but it might also be
that it's helping us to differentiate
how we talk from what we say right so
there's two axes how we say things is
that English is good French and what is
it that we're saying we're seeing the
same thing in these various languages
but and so the neural models are really
good at learning how we say things and
we're now working towards in you know
improving our ability to control what is
that so I mean it feels like when you
say why it feels like you're trying to
inject some kind of personality to it
that there's no finality there's
grounding you know like if so bills
previous example it was always you know
is the Starbucks open well that depends
on where you are
are we in Seattle what time is it it the
answer is needs to be grounded right so
that's the what it's going to say how
it's going to say that yes it is or hey
there's only ten minutes left till it
when it's open that's the how we're
seeing and it's worth saying that I
think this grounding is critically
important to loosing it that it's really
vital that we connect these
conversations to the world or it's just
blather and I think traditionally in
natural language processing we tended to
map from language into language whether
it's translation or summarization or
spelling grammar correction that kind of
thing but I think even if there are some
sort of useful application like if I get
a text message my friend says like I'm
feeling sick
you can maybe predicts how to respond to
them without even interesting any input
that they're typing in right sort of
they can confirm and send you know I
feel like we've talked about this a lot
and I want to see something now and I
want you to talk to it bill looks like
you've got some on your computer let's
see if letís put a lot it down to be
good let me just try an example uh well
I can do the one that Lucy sorry
something's kind of frequent like I'm
feeling
I'm feeling really sick today okay which
is really common you know you're going
to see that started a little slow and I
work I think there we go where this
again this is not being retrieved from a
corpus of responses this is being made
up by the neural model whereby word this
is a very high frequency kind of
exchange what and that's cool because
like like usually when I'm doing stuff
with machine like there's a specific
task but you just literally typed in I'm
feeling 66 today and to me that's like
that's that's not input that I would
give a computer right I mean it's cool
that you've been able to actually model
the typical responses for that kind of
thing being shown some more examples
yeah so why don't I just show you
something that let's see sometimes my
mother is coming actually am I good I'm
going to restart the context so it's not
affected by the prior terminal so when
you say it's not affected does it keep
like a stack of information or yeah i'm
various in the picture as we're taking
advantage of fire context to influence
what stuff so just I really just want to
point out the pronoun here that it's
getting sheep it's all the wealth one
sentence
yeah and the program is right if I said
something like her father
turns out over here because father
there's a deep model sorry so you see he
okay which again it's a very low level
kind of experience to show but it is
really fascinating even getting the
words right doing the electrical choice
very nice it's getting the word order
right it's getting the pronouns right
I'm very good at this kind of pattern
I mean indirect object pronouns when I
was doing research was the bane of NLP
is exactly and you would have imagined
that you would have to write a rule yeah
right you would imagine that we needed
to do a reference resolution and all of
that but it's just falling out from the
model because the models because they've
been trained on such huge amounts of
data they've learned how to I think so
what what could this be used for like
right now I like to me if someone's
watching this it doesn't know about NLP
and hasn't done research in this and
it's not like completely blown away
because I am what is this what would
this be used yeah I mean I think like a
sort of mentioned before just like if
you want to automatically generate
replies to an email or a text message
you can sort of you know can generate
something and just click send it but the
common responded I think there's also a
lot of opportunities to integrate this
in some more goal directed dialog for
some okay it's more like natural like
Pocky instead of like feeling like
really talking to your phone it's more
like you're talking to a person and
having a natural conversation right I
know I said that I think this notion of
grounding is really important in that
and where the leap to neural models from
the oldest statistical model is really
important because in these neural models
where everything's a vector we can
entangle linguistic information with
real-world information this is from a
photo something else in the environment
the state of your machine all of that
kind of things can be entangled in this
model that now knows something about
both language and its intersection with
your program state so we can begin to
now move away from this kind of chitchat
scenario we're really not trying to
build a chitchat model here
and Alan was saying we're trying to
build a model thing know is aware of
your world around you but also knows how
to engage you in a turn-taking
conversation and can its responses can
be influenced that potentially your
responses can influence the state of the
world is there a way offering like I'm
just going to say and again according
you know kind of if you follow the comp
cooperative principle of conversation
you don't want a computer that
robotically says I am talking at this
moment as we leave out a lot of
information as well because maybe you've
already told me that information so we
also wanted to to the how needs to be
natural and it will if the more natural
we can get a conversational agent to be
the more you're willing to interact with
it and to share with the conversational
for agent information about you it will
help it you it sounds later on I think
we're coming up with some of this
perspective that we're not trying to
build either a chitchat engine or a
purely transactional task oriented
dialogue a so we're trying to blend both
into the same model you're saying you
can take this conversational model and
blend it with for example your insurance
company box and what it will do is you
can start talking insurance to it and so
you get the model for insurance
knowledge with this sort of smoothing
model that's moving under it if you
think about renting a car at an airport
most of that conversation may be
transactional but there's likely to be
some sort of polite sugar in there the
personality character will be oh you're
going to the Grand Canyon but what is
beautiful out there today it's relevant
to the conversation but it's not
relevant to deciding what car you're
going to get or how many rates are going
to have it so we're anymore for that
combined model
well this has been really awesome
apparently run out of time it's just
good stuff I mean it touches to the
heart of some of the stuff that I got to
work on this is really impressive work
thanks so much for spending some time
with us thank you Bill and Lucy for your
time and fascinated especially we look
forward to hearing more about
conversational agents in the future also
not forgetting with
you
[Music]